welcome to this video round six of the
candidates and this video is about the
game Aronian claim white against a
dragon with black so on a game between
one of the contenders for the qualifying
spot Aronian and that wrecking was
really having a bad tournament with the
- score at the bottom of the table so
Aronian certainly looking to have to
press in this game and let's see what
happened yeah went see form Aronian
normally play d4 but he is flexible
about his first movie sometimes plays
Knight f3 and c4 - to avoid certain
things and invite others and Rickon
playing c6 okay is playing the Slav so
this makes some sense 9003
d5 and here we have a case where
starting with C form can make a
difference if the opponent is going from
a Slav kind of set up here white has
additional options and these are III
this has been played by tupelov in this
tournament against on an earlier it's
also the move b3 and there's the move g3
and of all of these moves g3 is maybe
the the sharpest move simply because
yeah black can respond in a very
principled way he can take the pawn and
this is what I'm drinking did what do we
have here is an opening that is usually
called the ready gambit a gambit line in
the reti opening the gambit is course
about the c4 pawn black if he wants
can't keep the pawn it's really possible
I'm gonna play Bishop g2
yeah and black can try to hold on to the
pawn it's not completely bad like d5 but
it is very rare risky white will attack
those pawns and have an excellent
development with pressure on the Queen
side
this is in fact one of my my main
opening sound any in tournament chess
and over the board chess this kind of
flank openings and I have played
numerous games with it so I'm able to
tell you some some things about the line
yeah Aronian sometimes playing on lines
like that varying his repertoire and
mallets see and Rickon is taking a turn
as mentioned the interesting thing here
is that if black does not take he has in
some way made a concession you know if
he plays Knight f6 Bishop d2 again he
can take and if he if he does not he has
to reckon with certain lines that all
have there there are you let's a slight
slight disadvantages for example Bishop
f5 is the line that after Queen b3 has a
problem with a b7 pawn here there are
interesting ways to play black can even
try for contact with 96 but okay I don't
want to stray too far away from that
I'm the capture on c4 is really the
principle move and and Reagan's choice
Bishop d2 and he played 97 yeah this is
an interesting way to play it tries to
keep the pawn form some more moves with
that idea I can show you to put the
night on b6
covering the pawn in that way the the
big advantage over b5 of course is that
the Queen side is not so seriously
weakened v5 really creates lots of holes
and we see that Andre Candice already
spending time here he's it seems that he
did not really expect this precise line
yeah here White has a choice of 7 a very
important choice it's not really
possible in the long run to - yeah - let
the point stay on c4 you need to get it
back at at
point and you can try with two different
with two different ways you can try with
93 this is what Aronian played or you
can play a four first this is an
important difference and the main
difference is that after a form like a
black will play a five that's almost
forced move and then 93 do we have from
a position from the game just with those
two moves inserted the big difference is
that now black has some possibilities to
just return the pawn and play a position
that is quite similar in nature to the
Slav with the B Foursquare weakened
let's say something like that
yeah just for argument's sake yeah here
black can at some point put the knight
on before and just claims to have a very
solid position it's still something that
white can try to to play it's not like
it's it's terrible for white but this is
an important point vector in the game he
played Knight a3 and here it is really
not so advisable for black to to not to
be principled and try to keep the pawn
with Bishop e6 if you return the pawn
here just without any any particular
fight this type of position quite often
gives white um slightly the better
chances at least I prefer by TM the idea
is that if you look at this type of
position white is not playing default
console but he plays something like d3
and it's just keeping a centre flexible
very often you would get a position
where white can even put the knight on
e5 putting some pressure on the Queen
side it's not the kind of position that
will net you yeah
quick mating attacks but it's it's very
comfortable for white to play you risk
absolutely nothing and you can always
try to press with little things on the
Queen side the more principled and
better move probably especially six
Drake in plate after which it will get
very very sharp quickly aronia playing
95 yeah insisting on getting the pawn
back and if white gets it back he's
certainly in good shape so black really
has to play the move on Drake in place
now Queen to d4 then the only move free
to justify what like did and well here
there's no turning back really white is
now taking on c6 very very funny
transposition now that on transposition
is wrong transformation of the position
um
yeah black needs to take this this night
if you return you could think about that
I mean the night does not have many
squares but you have the deform reply
and this instantly wins for white so you
need to take the night jack takes yet
here black has a choice he can play King
d8 or you can interpose on d7 it's oh
yeah it's it's tricky to say what's
what's best really and Drake in went
form for King d8 again after some
thought so he really seems to have been
caught in the same this line without any
particular preparation it seems so maybe
he just forgot what he had analyzed at
some some earlier point yeah there are
some trickier ideas um black plays this
for example here white has this tricky
move and ya note that black cannot take
checkmate quite quite a funny mate I
actually have one blitz games with that
not many but it happened um yeah that's
an interesting interesting try the
advantage of this is of course black
retains castling rights but he's got
terribly Janna the pieces are not very
well coordinated and Ricky plays King d8
you know and goes for goes for another
idea 95 is inserted and Queen to c5 yeah
white can also take here immediately but
now it's not so clear how this night is
going to get into plane this is why
night b5 is played and this is also a
big difference to the position with a4
and a5 inserted as they are there's
always night b5 as a root square in fact
I believe that the position with a4 a5
inserted exactly this position would be
excellent for why it's much better than
the game position here but as mentioned
a4 has has other drawbacks like this
this simple plan by black to just return
the pawn um I think it's better what
Aronian played first not b5 to attack
the Queen hmm it went to c5 and now why
took ya and TM and Rekha decided to take
the dangerous night on b5 and not the
bishop on 8th an interesting question
what's what's better here I mean this is
a playable move it's not it's not
terrible but I also understand that you
want to get the knight of the board jump
a 4 is probably what white is going to
play and there are some tactical ideas
based on this night which is a problem
let's say a 6 white can play deform and
all this looks very tricky yeah for
example with the idea to push the center
the knight on a 8 is not exactly great
yeah he decided to take on b5 which i
think is ok white returned to g2 and now
Bishop d7 and this is in fact a novelty
not never known it's not a prepared
novelty obviously because and reckoners
has spent like one of the modern 770
minutes yeah on the move that this
actually has actually been played here
is h5 played in three games and I
actually believe that dragons move the
stronger
he over the bottom improved on those
games they tried however is not terrible
I mean black is indeed intending to play
h4 and Queen h5 to get an attack himself
white should probably go here and then
Bishop f5 was tried this was played in a
game between yeah the Dutch chess legend
young teaming and black player was
Young's mates one of the younger -
players and teaming actually won a nice
game Ian vikon's a 2013 he fought it
continued its really an entirely
different position and rake it smooth
Bishop d7 as mentioned is new and
interesting
it simply clears the e pawn so black
continues to develop and in fact if you
take into account that he was surprised
he had had to find all this over the
board he's playing it really an
excellent absolutely great i mean ii
five now would be one all this seems to
be the most precise now he took on c4
and even grabbed on e - now we got c
decision but there is no direct attack
apparent I mean blacks pieces here do a
good job of guarding the King on d8 snow
were direct mating attack and I think
that the next moves are also pretty much
best played White's worst pieces this
Bishop so he gets it into play quickly
and Bishop a3 is also here allowing the
rook to immediately look at the a7 pawn
and yeah and rake in place Queen c4 and
Queen B one is also the best move
keeping the Queen's on to maintain max
maximum pressure trading it's really not
leading to much something like that
black and yeah I could black and play
something I kept like rook e8 for
instance you need to look at this threat
of course yeah and here
d2 is hanging and you have you if you
want to keep your porn that's probably
the movie form cutting this Bishop out
threatening 95 this seems to be okay for
black queen be one is the more logical
move anyway taking into account that
blacks King is still in the center and
black has also a disadvantage on the
clock so you want to in a way keep it
complicated of course if you can
transfer trans transpose into a really
good endgame you should do that but here
the endgame didn't promise much and on
general grounds quits on make sense iam
King e7 he wants to use the rook from a
Jade of course rook to coin a seven this
wasn't possible to save anyway and now
Queen D for the Queen has a really nice
position now one deform it cannot be
attacked by yeah any minor piece white
only has the light squared Bishop and
it's also safe from the text from the
rook at the moment and it's simply a
great centralized spot rook b79 a4 yeah
this was necessary but it's not a big
deal
the knight is nicely protected now rook
c1 was played this needs to get into
play and rook the eight yeah black could
think of nigera but the problem is that
white can check even take on d7 here
Queen d7 discreetly form and here it
gets really ugly something like that is
not going to end too well for black and
King b7 Jack does this check coming and
white as also winning easily here he
played rook the edge which is okay of
course you need to get this piece at the
play it was still on a jade and not
really participating yeah now h3 plate
to coverage reform all this seems very
sensible to me
and King f8 trying to secure the King
finally yeah and now after Queen b3
which also is quite quite a logical move
and tending route B form I think exactly
here and raking is playing the it's the
yeah almost the only mistake in the game
he plays before now up to now I think he
has defended really excellently note
that Aronian has even yeah spend more
time now in the last during the last
couple of moves on Dracon with no time
has defended excellently well he played
before now however and this is really a
technical mistake it it should lead to
white being a clearly better and in fact
this is what happens the move that he
probably underestimated or miscalculated
something about his rook c4 this was
played and yeah what should like do now
in plate Queen to d5 the thing is where
where should the Queen go
besides d5 you know if you take the pawn
white is simply going to take on a form
and this position is it's just winning
the bad thing is you cannot even take
here
checkmate because of the checkmate and
this means that black must keep an eye
on f7 or the Queen respectively so that
now Daniel played this move if why now
takes you can actually take here and
like it's in fact winning s you cannot
play that being white but you can first
give the check and this is the problem
after King g8 in this position aronia
played the move rook deform this in fact
should win the game but it's not the
most convincing way to play the even
stronger move was Bishop before him
and I think this probably immediately
would have ended the game not like on
this exact move but there I don't see
any any type of defense for Black Knight
takes e4 drew Kirby eight is the point
and what is black supposed to do now
very very difficult to suggest something
probably Bishop e8 is the the toughest
defense after takes takes rook takes we
get to a position where White has two
points and the rook against two minor
pieces and the activity of whites
position also pretty much indicates that
there will be a queen trade and this
endgame should be a really very easy win
something like it for example if black
plays Bishop c6 to activate the Bishop
rook c4
yeah probably need to get back even to
e8 Jim what should black play it's not
not easy to tell
maybe g6 yeah but just look at this if
you consider this endgame this endgame
is just a very simple win what will push
both pawns and this will cost one of the
lights one of the one of the minor
pieces this is probably even winning
with just the a pawn yeah unless black
immediately wins wins one back wins a
pawn back but with D and a pawn white
should win this quite quite easily so
bishop we formed in this position was a
good move but he played rook D form
which still should be enough and rakin
now played Queen to c6 and that it's
really the case
Queen c5 was somewhat tougher white
still is probably a much much better
after bit should be forward it was a bit
tougher than Queen c6 after Queen c6 now
Aronian played rugby takes this happen
yeah it's it's not a bad move and fairly
obvious but the thing is we
we'll beat xt7 leads to winning position
um Bishop takes e4 here again was even
stronger
they simply abscess no defense now for
black absolutely none if you consider
for example this check check
and this yeah white will take here and
the back rank is the problem that's
always made on the back rank and the
Knights are both completely yeah they're
lost all all kind of yeah stability it's
it's simply simply really bad here if
black takes here very important there's
this capture and what should black do
now yeah something like that okay check
check check mate that's nice so Bishop
before it's just flat-out winning I
don't see any kind of defense
Queen Queen here who can we can check
okay I'm going to take this is just a
terrible pin on on the default so rook
takes and now justice yes this is
absolutely impossible to survive for
black your two pawns down and you're
still pinned on the back rank it's it's
just completely dead this was a big
chance for ammonia to to directly grab
the game up what he did to rook B takes
t7 however is still leading to an
excellent position 97 and now Queen
takes a form this was obviously the idea
the computer as usual is completely
merciless and gives Queen e7 e also as
completely winning like a +3 position
but this is not really realistic for
human to play if you take on this heaven
you will take on a form
this is however from a technical point
of view I need to show the move because
it's the next position where Aronian
could have one like in one move black
black is completely defenseless the rook
is attacked and you're you're just in
terrible pain cm something like that you
will lose t7 back you have absolutely no
possibility to save yourself something
like that okay
check and this will win yeah it's a
computer line I mean it's there so I
should show it but this is not really a
realistic possibility that you take on
the 797 and then play Queen e7 but
Bishop before before was really a simple
move to to play okay what is it doing it
takes on a form it takes takes and now
the problem was as it turns out as I
read what he said in the press
conference that Aronian had to hadn't
really appreciated the move Knight to f8
he probably thought that f5 is the move
that black must play to save the pawn
and then after rook before white is very
simply winning because of the pin on the
D file something like that this is very
very simple because you get rooks off
and you will win with the a pawn but
black has this move in fact with a
counter-attack on the tool and yeah okay
Aronian already had how many spots three
or four spots where he could have won
instantly and the the weirdest thing is
exactly here and I really don't
understand what's going on now he now
took only four with the rook which is
yeah really completely strange I don't
understand at all why you would take
with the rook and I think you didn't
really have an explanation in the press
conference besides the fact that he was
really angry at himself that he still
didn't yeah that he hadn't finished the
game off earlier
the thing is you can just take with the
bishop and this is just the far more
harmonious move the thing is after after
something like that there is just this
move or 2:8 it's it's both good and now
you just push the a pawn and black is
completely helpless here there's
absolutely nothing you can do um yeah
you can try to activate you something
like that
a 496 a 5 but what should like do
something like that yeah I'm doing here
and I'll push the pawn it's just it's
just a very simple win white will
promote the pawn it it will take some
moves
yes but it's it's never in doubt that
white is going to win here with rookie
for rookie to a4 we get to position
where the rookies yam can put this on
the board where the rook is defending
the pawn from the side but you cannot
push it at the moment in the other
situation yeah yeah we're in in a pure
rook endgame yeah you would prefer to
have this cover from the side then have
it from from front of the forum but with
the bishop on the board
I mean rook is much better on a sameness
you can push the pawn here you cannot
even advance it and I really don't know
it cannot explain why he took with the
rope because the other move was just
it's just farm obvious I mean I actually
tried this evening giving this position
to two club mates of mine and they both
were completely shocked that he that he
didn't take with the bishop but with the
rook yeah very very strange decision
yeah what does black doing now black has
a simple job I mean he stays on the a
file and blocks the pawn and other than
that he activates the knight and
injustice and yeah why does the one to
show something now how he do you
actually advance your pawn in the Sun in
this situation
I I don't really know to be honest a
couple of moves later we got to this
position and here amazingly enough
aronia decided to take the bishop which
is I don't know it's very strange why
would you give up your stronger minded
piece here for the night
I still I personally would have still
tried to keep this on the board cover
the pawn and maybe try to get the rook
somewhere I don't know like here here
I'm not sure if you managed but the the
simple thing is I believe or the the
true this if you trade this is what
aronia did I don't think that white can
win anymore this I mean yeah you must be
cautious about those kind of first
statements but it feels like black has a
really decent drawing chances now
because I'm not quite sure how white is
going to ever get the King over with
yeah well the only winning idea to to
start like that would be to get the king
over but of course there is counter play
against White's pawns by the rook and
the pawn is relatively far back being on
the fourth rank I really have my doubts
that there is some realistic winning
chance and this so it's it's really
surprising that he took only six I think
in the press conference I only and said
that he was so angry at himself that he
simply didn't care anymore but okay it's
always difficult to to tell what those
kind of statements really mean yeah well
I play droopy for King f7 and there we
can put some more moves on the board and
we see that it's really difficult now
for white to get anywhere this is just a
very active rook it looks at the
porns it cannot advance it detects the
f-pawn and if whites try something like
a form this is in fact he didn't let him
he played the King do you want first
setting this little trap boss this is
winning after he decided to play a four
but the thing is how do you ever get
ahead here if you let me keep it to keep
it protected yeah if you always have two
pawns that are attacked by the rook on a
- yeah okay
inflate f4 and now rook a3 you cannot
save the G born after those moves they
agreed to a draw now it's completely
dead we get all pawns exchanged so a
very disappointing game certainly for
Aronian who had like three or four
direct wins
yeah maybe three direct wins one of them
quite computer ish I admit a bit
the thing is that moves like here Bishop
takes d4 in this position is really for
a player of his strength
yeah this is something that he would
usually find if you wake him up at night
for him and he's completely dizzy he
will still see the move normally quite
quite weird maybe he just had an off day
and yeah but it's a very important point
in this tournament that simply have a
point missing he had so many chances to
win the game and it's at the end it's
it's just rough this might hurt in the
in the long run
okay I hope you enjoyed the coverage
I'll be back on Friday because after the
sixth round today we have a rest day so
the final round of the first turn of
this tournament will be played on Friday
and I'll be back then with new video
coverage thanks for watching